et puis suspense pour le dépôt des
listes et en guyane où il y aura une
triangulaire en fin de compte la gauche
s'annonçait en ordre dispersé avec trois
listes mais une alliance par sienne
s'est fait à la dernière minute 17h53 à
7 minutes de la fermeture de la
préfecture c'est la limite la fdj
viennent déposer leurs listes
monsieur oui vous avez attendu la
dernière minute pour quoi ça dès qu'on
est dans les temps c'est l'essentiel
a priori la liste pour une guyane qui
bouge ne devrait pas changer
mais coup de théâtre les représentants
des walwari arrive c'est la confusion
discussions les deux parties composent
une liste d'alliance les cases blanches
sans un pli des noms de la liste taubira
apparaissent avec ceux des fdg trois
quarts d'heure plus tard tout devient
plus clair lève des jets se sont bien
associé à walwari et georges othily et
est de l'île
le préalable pour faire une fusion était
que monsieur hot chilli soit président
écoutez je dois pas pourquoi nous
n'aurions pas eu ce prêt est là d'une
tradition qui cheikh baye en tête de
liste qui s'incline par rapport une
autre face au fdg walwari deux autres
listes la liste ps j'ai conduite par
antoine karam et la liste ump de léon
bertrand mais trois listes donc dimanche
prochain en guyane celle du président
sortant antoine karam du parti
socialiste guyanais celle de l'ancienne
candidate à la présidentielle christiane
taubira qui a fusionné en laissant la
tête de liste au sénateur divers gauche
de georges othily et enfin la liste ump
du ministre candidat